donc maintenant depuis que tu as fait ça
de il ya plus il s'est moqué
l'administrateur depuis qui a fait ça et
on est passé de 700 à moins de 100
aujourd'hui mais très peu de licences
picasso il y en a une dizaine il ya
d'autres artistes il ya eu la voiture et
voitures il ya évidemment l'art de la
table parce qu'on demande à reproduire
des visages sur des assiettes il ya les
foulards et les t-shirts parce que tout
le monde en demande
et encore quelques petites licences très
très isolée il y en a une dizaine à tout
casser pour par une comparaison si on
regarde magritte il ya 250 licence mais
ouais donc on est quand même très très
très limité parce que la famille en a
pas besoin mais si on ne fait rien ouais
c'est le bordel tu delft la porte
ouverte voilà c'est le bordel à l'eau
ouais oui même si ma fille commençait à
la maintenance ouais mais je suis en
train de dîner avec mes amis
bah ouais tu peux oui tout à fait oui
que ce temps pose qu'on soit là moi je
pense que ça serait bien sûr les relais
on est d'accord mais ça quand jacques
semblait d'accord que ricco chacun
fredo main olivier picasso bianca li
d'accord le conseil est d'accord ça va
15en oral d'anglais
c'est bien maintenant elle a des bonnes
notes man on man one vote soit vraiment
c'est bien maintenant
dix huit en or à l'espagne tu parles
espagnole hispania et tu parle espagnol
mon attention
tu peux venir alors que tu viens me pose
est venu à la guérilla
quand jamie gold problème en
combinant merial à aullène ali daffé 1
elle met bien sorti
quand il n'y a pas de problème tu peux
venir demain à 7 heures ça pas mal ça
passera y'a pas de problème tu as bien
fait d'appeler m
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus